well over the past two weeks more than
45,000 people have arrived in Copenhagen
hoping to witness the birth of an
historic global climate ear many of
those who have turned up up and left
disappointed before the final curtain
was even drawn on Jill as overcrowding
less than a shin the curls but for those
of us lucky enough to get inside the
bella center we have watched eagerly as
nations have engaged in an epic struggle
to solve what is arguably the world's
most complex problem it's well past
midnight here on the final day of the
negotiations and I'm absolutely
exhausted world's leaders were supposed
to sign a global deal here at 3pm today
but who knows when that's going to
happen press conferences of the schedule
throughout the day only to be cancelled
something of a mob mentality has emerged
among the press with journalists
literally chasing politicians down
corridors and hanging around outside the
plenary session hoping to get a glimpse
of what's going on somehow draft
documents are being obtained
surreptitiously and being passed around
the press room but really no one knows
when a final deal will emerge
we also believe that you will all be
stronger all be safer all be more secure
if we act together
start with absolute chaos but it was
very worthwhile I finally got to see a
glimpse of Obama do we have a deal man
world leaders weren't the only
celebrities here however earlier today
we caught up with Radiohead frontman
Thom Yorke who came to Copenhagen
concerns the deal was on the verge of
collapse I wanted to see this in
operation I wanted to come and like find
some something of hope in this because I
was actually sick of hearing people on
the radio and friends of mine dismissing
this not a [ __ ] lot no would you like
to see how I would have liked to seen
proper leadership from the EU but with
200 nations here to broker a deal what's
the best possible outcome that could be
held for while waiting for the
announcement I pose that question to
three people who've been studying the
negotiations here closely I wanted to
know what would signal success for them
in Copenhagen I'd like to see three
elements we came in to Copenhagen with
some political pledges on the table all
of the major economies have put numbers
on the table I'd like to see those
included in a final decision here I'd
also like to see some progress on the
question of verification how are we
going to be sure the countries are
actually keeping their promises I don't
know that will decide that fully here
but at least get started on that and
third I think we need a firm deadline
for getting to a legally binding
agreement those are the three elements
I'd like to say for Copenhagen to be a
success I don't actually think in those
terms I have to tell you I think the
most important thing that could happen
would be a Barack Obama would go home
tell the American people we need to get
through the Senate a cap-and-trade bill
a carbon tax and a gasoline tax because
we are going to take the lead in the
world's next great global industry clean
tech and we're going to tell china and
europe and japan it's game on we're now
in the earth race okay it's game on for
who can invent the most clean
technologies and i think we will invent
and innovate more clean tech that will
eliminate more co2 emissions by America
taking the lead and other people
competing with us in emulating us than
we ever will do through a treaty that is
voluntary non-binding global
will be a very difficult sell in the
United States of America for the first
time ever something like a common
climate protection goal but is the two
degrees target has to be something which
has to be acknowledged by the entire
community of the world the Kyoto
Protocol is expiring before 2012 so we
know if we want to have something
ratified and so on I guess next year
actually we have to come up with a
legally binding deal that's it of course
I could argue from a scientific point of
view but if you put together all the
things which are on the table now when
we will probably get a bird which is at
least three point five degrees warmer so
that's the current standing and we have
to open a pathway which allows us for
measures to bring it down actually 22
degrees
it's late Saturday afternoon here in the
bella center and i finally managed to
catch up on a few hours sleep so i'm
feeling a lot less tired than i was last
night as you can see the atmosphere here
has gone from chaotic to positively
quiet the negotiations have finished but
did copenhagen actually deliver on its
expectations late last night the u.s.
forged a deal with four other nations
South Africa Brazil India and China
called the Copenhagen Accord this deal
agrees for the need to limit warming to
two degrees and it also outlines
financing to help the world's poorest
nations cope with climate change but
many of the UN member states have not
endorsed this deal and it's been widely
criticized by many delegations as well
as why environmentalists in short the
Copenhagen Accord falls down on several
fronts perhaps most importantly however
it fails to actually include national
targets for emissions reductions which
means that we're committed to more than
three degrees of warming something that
john shell nuber was worried would
happen speaking to the press here at the
bella center today a very tired looking
evo deboer listed all that was missing
from the UN accord
so for us not an accord that is needed
final not an accord that this one pins
down in our countries to individual
times North reported this stage
specifies about many other coming not an
important this definitely a million of
what the Copenhagen Accord could do and
this would be significant is to help
domestic legislation passed through the
US Senate the US came here wanting China
to agree to external verification of its
emissions cuts and the u.s. got what it
wanted but did other nations get a fair
deal looking back to the bally climate
conference in 2007 hopes for Copenhagen
were extremely high copenhagen was
supposed to be the birthplace of a
globally binding treaty to avoid
dangerous climate change for now that
ambition seems to be shelved on till
december 2010 when the UN climate
conference will meet again in mexico for
now though that's all from was from
Copenhagen but check next week's issue
of nature for a more detailed breakdown
of cobb 15 and of course we'll be taking
you into the new year with coverage on
nature reports climate change
you
you